also from our eight news now
investigators new details about the
woman who once claimed she was too
pretty to be arrested who is now accused
of killing her mother we do want to warn
you the images may be disturbing a news
now investigator David Charles reports
from downtown Las Vegas with more
29-year-old hen bustami is accused of
killing her mother by allegedly breaking
a coffee table over her head and then
stabbing her with shards of glass now
we've learned that prosecutors will not
seek the death penalty against her do
you need police fire or medical
I know because I think I killed my mommy
Peters say hen bustami claims to have
killed her mother in this 911
because I did I I murdered her how did
you do that yeah
the eight news now investigators
obtaining this photo of that table which
shows it broken on a bedroom floor in
this South Valley neighborhood homicide
detectives believe bustami took pieces
of glass stabbing her mother 61 year old
afaf huson in Grand Jury transcripts
revealing bustami told police she asked
her mother for cigarettes when they
began to argue she then reportedly broke
the table over her mother's head then
calling 9-1-1 what did you do to her
police say bustami then hung up and
drove down I-15 toward California
Highway Patrol there arresting her
police say they found her covered in
blood noting these Cuts in images the
eight news now investigators obtained on
her hands bustami pleading not guilty a
trial date not yet set outside the
Regional Justice Center in downtown Las
Vegas I'm David charns 8 News Now
as our 8 news now team first reported
bustami as the same woman who told
police at Reed airport last summer again
that she was too good-looking to be
taken into custody now Metro arrested
bustam before allegedly not paying a
restaurant bill in that case and then
arguing with officers prosecutors have
since dropped that charge